>> Dana: A LIBERAL CITY IS
WARNING PEOPLE TO BE CAREFUL
WHAT THEY WERE TO AVOID GETTING
AROUND.
IT'S TERRIBLE NEWS FOR
JUDGE JEANINE.
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT SAYING WHAT WE ARE
ASKING THE PUBLIC TO DO IS IF
THEY'RE GOING TO WEAR EXPENSIVE
JEWELRY OR DRIVE HIGH-END CARS,
WHEN LEAVING RESTAURANTS,
TAVERNS AND OTHER LOCATIONS,
THEY NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF THEIR
SURROUNDINGS AND BEING WELL-LIT
AREAS.
RISING CRIME ISN'T JUST A
WEST COAST PROBLEM.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
BEING CRITICIZED FOR TALKING THE
LORI LIGHTFOOT.
HE PROBABLY SHOULD'VE CALLED
RON DeSANTIS.
WHERE ARE YOU CALLING THE PLACE
WHERE IT'S BAD?
>> Greg: IT DOES EXPLAIN WHY
NEW YORK CITY HAS BECOME LIKE
CHICAGO.
HOW MANY MASS SHOOTINGS OVER THE
WEEKEND, THAT IS CHICAGO.
YOU CAN'T WEAR JEWELRY OR DRIVE
HIGH-END CARS.
THIS IS THE PROPERTY VERSION OF
DON'T GO OUT IN A SHORT SKIRT.
RATHER THAN CHANGE CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR THROUGH PUNISHMENT, WE
THE LAW-ABIDING MUST CHANGE OUR
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE OUR POLITICAL
LEADERS ARE TOO SCARED OF THE
WOKE THAT HAS INFILTRATED OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S MADE THE CRITICISM OF
CRIMINALITY A SIGN OF RACISM
WHICH IS ACTUALLY MORE RACIST
THAN ANYTHING BECAUSE WHEN YOU
ASSOCIATE CRIME WITH MINORITIES,
THAT'S RACIST.
THAT'S WHAT THE HARD LEFT
PROGRESSIVES HAVE DONE.
IT'S WHY EVERYBODY IS REALLY
SCARED.
A FEW TALK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE STREETS AND THINGS YOU
SEE TO PEOPLE, PEOPLE WON'T JOIN
IN AND TALK TO YOU.
MY GOD, I DON'T WANT TO OFFEND
ANYBODY.
TALKING ABOUT CRIME IS
CONSIDERED A DOG WHISTLE.
>> Dana: JUDGE, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO?
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M NOT IN A
POSITION TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
NOW BUT WHEN I WAS, NOBODY WOULD
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THESE CASES IN A GRAND JURY.
IT'S CALLED VICTIM BLAINE.
IF YOU WEAR THIS SKIRT TOO
SHORT.
IF YOU WERE ROLEX.
WHEN YOU'RE OUT THERE ENJOYING
THE FRUITS OF YOUR LABOR IF
YOU'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE A
NICE CAR THEN YOU'RE TEASING THE
CRIMINAL WITH IT.
HERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
YOUR LIFE IS FOREVER AFFECTED BY
IT.
YOU'RE AFRAID FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE LOOKING OVER YOUR
SHOULDER FOR THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE WHILE THE CRIMINALS
BEHAVIOR DOESN'T CHANGE.
HE JUST GOES THROUGH THAT
SWINGING DOOR OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
RARELY WILL HE EVEN GET
PROSECUTED.
IN THE END THAT, THERE'S ONLY
ONE WAY TO HANDLE IT.
GETTING RID OF NO BAIL, MAKING
SURE WE GET RID OF THESE WOKE
PROSECUTORS WHO WERE MORE
INTERESTED IN, AND ALSO THEY
AREN'T VICTIMS.
THIS IS THE PERFECT EXAMPLE.
YOUR PEOPLE CHANGING THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS
SEGMENT, I WAS READING ABOUT
MAYOR ADAMS, WE ARE ALL WILLING
TO GIVE NEW YORK CITY THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
HE GOES TO LORI LIGHTFOOT TO
FIND OUT HOW TO FILE CRIME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN
WATCHING THE NEWS FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
CHICAGO IS A NIGHTMARE.
SO THE REPORTER SAYS EVERY TIME
I ASK HIM A VIOLENT CRIME YOU
SAY CRIME IS DOWN.
THIS IS TO LORI LIGHTFOOT.
CRIME IS NOT DOWN.
CRIME IN CHICAGO WAS UP BY 34%.
SHE GETS ANGRY.
178% INCREASE IN CARJACKINGS IN
YOUR CITY AND LIFELESS RESPONSE
TO THE QUESTION, YOU ARE ONE OF
THE RUDEST PEOPLE I'VE EVER MET.
THE REPORTER SAYS I THINK
CARJACKERS ARE RUDE PEOPLE BUT
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
WOKE MAYORS, JUDGES,
PROSECUTORS.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE BEEN A
LIFELONG NEW YORKER.
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> Jessica: HAVING BEEN HERE,
ALMOST 40 YEARS.
YOU CAN'T CALL MARY ADAMS WOKE.
YOU CAN'T.
IF YOU'VE BEEN LISTENING TO HOW
HE RAN HOME.
PROGRESSIVES KNOW THEY ARE NOT
HAPPY WITH HIM.
THIS WAS NOT THE CANDIDATE THEY
WANTED.
THIS WAS MORE OF THE TOUGH ON
CRIME CANDIDATE THAT UNITED
MINORITY VOTERS AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS.
LIBERALS WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
CARJACKINGS AND THINGS LIKE
RATING DRUG STORIES, BREAKING
THE WINDOWS AT CHANEL AND
WHATEVER ELSE THEY'RE GOING TO
DO.
I THINK THESE TIPS MAKE SOME
SENSE CONSIDERING THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT BUT IT'S NOT A
SOLUTION AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
YOU CAN SAY IS LONG-TERM
SUSTAINABLE TO SAY DON'T WEAR
NICE THINGS THAT YOU WORKED
REALLY HARD TO GET A PURCHASE.
OR THINK TWICE IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GET YOUR KID A NICER CAR
VERSUS A USED CAR FROM 15 YEARS
AGO.
I THINK THESE TIPS FOR THE
MOMENT NEED TO BE COUPLED WITH
THE REAL WORLD SOLUTIONS THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING FORWARD.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A FRIEND IN
LOS ANGELES AND WHEN HE GOES OUT
ON DATES HE WILL RENT A
LAMBORGHINI FOR THE NIGHT AND
GET A LOAN OR WATCH TO IMPRESS
THE GIRL.
HE WILL PICK HER UP AND ROLL UP
AT A HOT SPOT AND GET OUT AND HE
WILL FLEX.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO NLA.
IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN L.A.,
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT?
ARE YOU GOING TO PULL UP IN A
BUICK WITH A SEIKO?
YOU MIGHT AS WELL BE IN
DES MOINES, IOWA.
L.A. IS ALL ABOUT HOT CARS, NICE
JEWELRY, AND BEING FAKE OR
APPEARING SUCCESSFUL.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT PEOPLE IN L.A.
DO?
THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF MONEY.
WHAT DO THEY DO?
I DON'T KNOW BUT THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY IMPRESSING ME WITH
ALL OF THEIR STUFF.
IF YOU CAN TO GO OUT AND NOT
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING
JACKED, ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO BE
YOUR OWN POLICEMAN, YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE CHECKING.
YOU'RE DOING YOUR THING.
THAT'S THE POLICE OFFICERS JOB,
THE CITY LEADERSHIP.
IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO PROTECT
YOU, A TAX CUT?
YOU'RE PAYING ALL THIS MONEY FOR
THEM TO PROTECT YOU SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PROTECT YOURSELF AND
YOUR SAYING THAT YOU HAVE TO
PROTECT YOURSELF.
GIVE ME MY MONEY BACK.
WHAT AM I PAYING THESE TAXES
FOR?
THE WHOLE THING IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR
BUDDY SHOULD DO, SHOULD RENT A
COP.
HUGE POWER MOVE.
TELL YOUR FRIEND